power rankings time completely
meaningless but nevertheless compelling
everybody has them but it's our way of
tearing down the lines and the walls
that separate divisions and conferences
and putting all the teams into one
bucket who are the best teams in the NFL
and Chris you know this this week the
top five and I can't remember a time
this has happened definitely not this
year the top five completely unchanged
in the Power Rankings Patriots 49ers
Saints Packers Ravens one two three four
five now the Ravens didn't play so they
weren't going to rise or fall but the
top four teams all won and we see no
changes the rest of the top ten the
Seahawks jump one from number seven to
number six after beating the Falcons the
Vikings jump one from eight to seven
after beating Washington the Bills fell
two spots after losing at home to the
Eagles Colts up two to number nine Rams
up two to number ten any problems any
complaints any issues with the top ten
okay well first off I just want to know
was there any thought about one and two
being switched any thought would you
have did you think about maybe making
the 49ers one no no no yeah I mean even
though it is funny though one of the
teams one of the teams the Patriots
struggle with and they only play them
once every four years they struggle with
the Panthers
the 49ers did not struggle with the
Panthers at all I just I can't that the
Patriots are the king of the hill they
won the Super Bowl the Super Bowl
champion is always installed as number
one for me until they lose and the
Patriots haven't lost and I can't
justify knocking them out of number one
until they lie I get you I probably
would have done the same thing but I
would have thought about it a little bit
I mean the 49ers it's very close so it's
almost like you know you may I don't
want you to do this but you almost could
make it tie it one right now that's how
good I mean oh no no no I can't have a
time you dare do it but no I mean you
look at the 49ers wins and I think you
could go they've had more impressive
wins they both play the Cleveland Browns
you know at home I the 49ers beat them
by more than the the New England
Patriots it's very close I'm being
nitpicky but I do find it interesting
how you know one the the San Francisco
offense is better than New England's
sense and then on the other side of the
ball right now
you know defensively we're all raving
about the Patriots defense but the
number one demons in football is the San
Francisco 49ers letting up what 20 less
yards passing a game than the great New
England Patriots defense that we all
talk about so I'm just saying it's an
interesting thought I think the 49ers
and and the New England Patriots are
clearly one and two it's very close
they're my other one I'll just give it
to you I think I would have the Rams who
you have a 10 I think I would have them
at 8 and then the bills and Colts at 9
and 10 I think I would have put them
above them I know they have one more
loss but I just think in a head-to-head
matchup they're gonna win that game that
would probably be my biggest grievance
of yours in the top 10 again this is not
a projection of who would win this is
where the franchise's currently are and
the Rams were not overly impressive in
their victory over the Cincinnati
Bengals they were in London on Sunday so
that that kept me from I thought about
moving them up even higher but you know
what the Colts weren't impressive either
the problem is the Chiefs lost and they
fell to five and three so they had to
drop a little bit but I gave the Colts a
little bit of a bump because they are
five and two yeah you can't you can't
deny the fact that they're five and two
so they move from 11 up to number 9 in
large part because the team that was
ahead of him at number 10 the Chiefs
lost they were at number 9 and the
Panthers they got blown out so they fell
out of the number 10 spot let's move on
to the second tenth since we're starting
to delve into that direction the Chiefs
are number 11 following two spots after
losing at home to the Packers Texans
climbed two spots to number 12 after
beating the Raiders the Cowboys hold
steady at number 13 they did not play
Eagles move up one spot after beating
the bills that was kind of tough for me
but how much higher do I move them
there's still only four and four yeah
Panthers fell five spots down to number
15 after getting blown out jaguars move
up 1 to number 16 after winning at home
against the Jets Steelers move up a spot
after beating the Dolphins Lions move up
a spot after beating the Giants
is up a spot after beating the
Buccaneers a game they shouldn't have
won and the Raiders fall four spots to
number 20 and I you can't have an
objection but the second ten no I'm
looking at it now revisiting it I think
that it said that I got it just right no
I think it's pretty close I probably
would have made the Texans 11 and the
Chiefs 12 right now but that's nitpicky
I get that a Texans did beat the Chiefs
yeah Texas did beat the chase yep so
that that's the only one I think the
rest of it I do I agree with you there I
do think the Eagles at 14 and I would
have put them there as well so I'm not
disagreeing with you but I just don't
want to say this watch out the Eagles
that was the best game they played last
week they looked like a different team
Fletcher Cox was F in the play up all
game long you know they're healthy at
corner so I thought their defense looked
much improved last week and if they get
that running game going as we saw
against the Buffalo Bills which is very
surprising because Buffalo is phenomenal
front seven the Eagles could be a team
that you know crack cracks into your top
ten here over the next few weeks I
certainly liked what I saw there up in
Buffalo here's my complaint about the
Eagles and it's partial praise but I'm
also concerned and I made this comment
in the in the actual Power Rankings that
we have at Pro Football Talk comm if
they played when their backs weren't
against the wall the way that they play
when their backs are against the wall
they'd never have their backs against
the wall I know like why do they wait
until it feels like this season is
falling apart to put together their best
performance of the year where's that
urgency earlier in the season where's
that urgency and you know it's kind of
like the the microcosm of I think the
game is the microcosm of the season
because how many games have they fallen
behind and then tried to wake it up yeah
like what is it about these Eagles that
they need to be in panic mode before
they perform at their best it's it's
hard to you know put a finger on it and
really figure out what it is about them
that's like that you know maybe a little
complacency you know I think maybe they
think yeah you know everybody picked
them to be in a Super Bowl contender in
the Super Bowl whatever it may be so
maybe that gets in their ears you know a
little bit of a cockiness I guess to a
degree the other
is the injuries I think the injuries is
a very real thing with Philadelphia and
they kind of had to not only just
withstand the storm of trying to get
healthy and and be competitive but it
affect their team schematically on both
sides and everything like that to where
yeah they're getting healthy now and I
say watch out but it is it is weird how
they are like that that they seem to
thrive when everybody thinks they're
done and they regroup us it says a lot
to Doug Peterson but I don't know why
they dig themselves in these holes
either let's continue on through the
back half back portion of the NFL yeah
and we got we got to give these teams a
little bit of consideration and look the
Chargers moved up six spots by virtue of
a game they should have lost only
because every other team in front of
them stinks and every other team in
front of them lost so I had no choice
but to move the charges up six spots the
Browns dropped one the Bears dropped one
the Cardinals dropped one the Broncos
dropped one and the Buccaneers hold firm
even though they lost that's a game they
probably should have won Giants actually
move up a spot despite losing to the
Lions they weren't horrible or at least
as horrible as they could have been Jets
down to number 28 Falcons still at 29
Washington moves up a space by only
losing by 10 points to the Vikings in
large part because the Bengals said oh
and they finally have to settle in to
number 31
dolphins holding firm at 32 and Krys
week 17 it's coming the Bengals and the
Dolphins all day together to determine
who will have the first overall pick in
the draft showdown we've all been
waiting for
I probably would make the bengals 32 and
the Dolphins 31 right now but who really
cares I mean it is amazing it does seem
like a year more than ever that the the
upper class is you know it's it's way
more significant than the rest of the
NFL here's a question I have for you
just like just to to talk some ball here
like where's the line of demarcation of
teams where you go these are legitimate
like Super Bowl contenders I'm not
saying to win the Super Bowl
but could you could you could make a
case that oh they could get in the Super
Bowl is it 14 at the Eagles there's a 14
you know back team that's not like you
take that the Panthers is Jack
Wars is being quite in that conversation
like maybe payoff contenders but you
don't think Super Bowl is realistic to
say to them right
not unless Cam Newton walks through that
door at 100% Superman 2015 MVP Cam
Newton soon yeah
it's 14 and the rest of them I'd be
shocked if any of those teams become
viable Super Bowl contenders yeah I'm
with you there too you know I certainly
like the Panthers and I think the
Jaguars can be a pain in the butt but
yeah it would take Cam Newton to get
back on and be on right away from the
get-go which I think we saw a little
last week you know we haven't talked
about that game a whole lot and you know
Kyle Allen certainly had his worst game
of the year hey he's been they've been
fortunate to play some teams while Kyle
Allen has started a quarterback to where
yeah they match up really well with now
we'll see this is not a great matchup
this week with the Tennessee Titans but
you know the thing I came to more than
anything last week watching the Panthers
play who you have at 15 on your Power
Rankings where I just said you know Kyle
Allen it's good and everything like that
but if the Panthers want to play with
the big boys in the NFL and especially
in the NFC they need number one and you
know some of the shots that have been
taking it you know Cam Newton at Oh Kyle
Allen's harder to defend because he'll
check the ball down like challenge flag
BS like BS on that crap I mean guys an
MVP he's played at a high level and like
for a coach to say that that was wrong I
was wrong I don't know other way to say
the Panthers are at their best when Cam
Newton's healthy and if he can get back
out there I still think they're a team
that you know can maybe turn it around
and make you and I change our opinion to
go ooh maybe they can be a Super Bowl
contender hey one last point we had
mentioned the Bengals and you said you
would put them at number 32 the
difference between the Dolphins and the
Bengals this year the Dolphins were
trying to lose the Bengals weren't but
now that they're Owen eight Andy Dalton
yesterday on his birthday was benched
yeah for Ryan Finley and look they want
to see what Ryan Finley can do that's
fine but anytime you want to evaluate
what younger players can do you no
longer are putting a premium and a
priority on winning which is fine and
I'm fine with acknowledging that we're
bad let's go ahead and be as bad as we
can be let's not worry about winning
these games because the reward is we're
going to draft higher and maybe there'll
be
able to get their franchise quarterback
Chris and 2020 some some unlucky college
football player who is achieving at the
highest level of the sport is going to
be the quarterback of the Bengals next
year yeah well yes that's that's the the
downfall of being awesome in college and
being in that conversation for the first
pick you're gonna go to a crap team and
have a tough road ahead of you and it
won't be easy but yes it certainly seems
like both of those teams are gonna be in
the business for quarterbacks and the
Bengals I think that's the proper
decision just to button up this
conversation you know they got to see
what they got Ryan Finley I think they
know that like the Andy Dalton era is
over okay we'll move on but you know if
Ryan Finley comes here and blows us all
away the last eight weeks of the year
they might go okay like maybe we got the
guy for the future let's see what he's
got and then they can you know worry
about using some of those assets on
other positions on their team that they
dearly need to fill
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports